[Musica]
c'è un confine impalpabile in quella
stanza d'ospedale
il primo piano il volto di donna
completamente coperta da delle bende
sullo sfondo delle sagome di due figure
coperte idrac amici e mascherine che
continuano a parlare di quell'operazione
che avrebbe dovuto restituire i
lineamenti a quella donna e un'attesa
infinita seguita da un lentissimo
srotolamento di quelle band che rivela
un volto di donna bellissima
solo che quando lei si vede allo
specchio urla inorridita e solo in quel
momento noi vediamo come sono le facce
delle altre persone sono grottesche
mostruosi ai nostri occhi ma in quel
mondo rovesciato la sua bellezza e
mostruosità e il suo disagio va trattato
eva sedato sono cresciuto con le storie
di ai confini della realtà
fantastiche persone ordinarie alle prese
con una situazione straordinaria e
improvvisamente un colpo di scena finale
che cambia completamente ci costringe a
cambiare la prospettiva e ci dà una
nuova consapevolezza di quello che è
successo una lettura completamente
diversa e tutto sommato è quello che ci
è successo con questo dramma del comite
qualcosa di impensabile che
improvvisamente si costringe a dire
guardare e di leggere tutto in un modo
diverso credevo fossero soltanto storie
belle invece ho scoperto dopo anni che
in quelle storie c'era un condensato
delle ansie delle paure di quegli anni
il conformismo la paura del diverso la
xenofobia l'ossessione della guerra
atomica
twilight poi sta per una linea soffusa
quindi non è una linea ben definita e
una sorta di linea di crepuscolo il
confine tra la luce e l'ombra tra la
fantasia e la realtà non è così ben
definito e questo ci mette a disagio a
disagio in qualche modo ma non è una
novità tutto sommato dall'inizio del
novecento che l'arte figurativa ma non
solo anche la musica le linee della
melody e dell'armonia sono stati in
qualche modo scompaginate questo ci ha
creato un disagio ma contemporaneamente
ha spostato i confini della nostra
conoscenza e dalle argati quindi
sappiamo sempre di più per non parlare
poi del confine tra spazio e tempo che
forse quello che più ci mette a disagio
il problema però è che gli ultimi anni
la quantità di conoscenze che ci arriva
addosso la velocità con cui cambiano e
si spostano questi confini è tale e
tanta che noi siamo completamente
disorientati e una sorta di onda che
rischia di travolgerci ed ecco il motivo
del successo delle fake news molti si
vogliono aggrappare a delle certezze
granitiche
se poi sono false non importa voglio
essere confortato da queste certezze ma
se di fronte a quello honda che rischia
di travolgerci ci fosse un'alternativa
ad aggrapparsi a dei salvagenti di
granito
o pochi minuti per cercare di convincere
di quanto è importante andare per
disordine e fidatevi sono la persona
giusta sono cintura nera di cdc
collegamenti e del cavolo e quindi c'è
una volta 3 princes pilota 12 volte tre
principi i primi solo dei orfani degli
orfani hawaiani che studiano vicino san
francisco pendono uno dei primi treni
che arriva nel 1885 a santa cruz e
scoprono le stesse gigantesche onde che
ci sono nelle loro isole e fanno
qualcosa che nessuno aveva visto fare
che impressiona moltissimo i
californiani tutto sommato sono gli
abitanti di un territorio che sta la
fine di questa corsa e rischiosissima
verso ovest cavalcano le onde questa
metafora del controllare qualcosa che
non puoi controllare il self gli altri
tre sono principi protagonisti di una
favola che fa parte di una raccolta di
farlo in persiano uscite alla fine
cinquecento a venezia i tre principi di
sedere di belen di per l'antico nome
dello sri lanka solo dei giovani saggi e
curiosi che fanno scoperte straordinarie
fantastiche di cose che non stavano
cercando
ma che mai avrebbero trovato se non si
fossero messi alla ricerca
due secoli dopo ora su colpo il pioniere
del romanticismo in una lettera scritta
a firenze cattura lo spirito di quella
favola e scrive con il neologismo che
oggi per noi è cruciale serendipity non
è solo la storia del signor colombo
cristoforo che per andare in india
sapete va dall'altra parte sapete cosa è
successo o no una buona parte dei nostri
progressi scientifici delle invenzioni
delle scoperte
sono stati determinati da scelte da
scoperte casuali ispirate però soltanto
a persone che erano messe alla ricerca e
quindi e quindi il self che ci deve
guidare ovviamente è la curiosità questo
vuol dire che trasformare l'onda che ci
sta per schiacciare in qualcosa che ci
fa volare gli chiede di dimenticarsi
tante cose che abbiamo studiato a scuola
collegamenti nazionali le cronologie e
andando calcolando dei percorsi che sono
connessioni eccentriche stampa la tesi
catture in quella complessità un
significato che sfugge al pensiero
lineare una metafora del pensiero
laterale e dunque io salto e faccio
alcune di queste connessioni tutte le
nostre storie sono legate a storie
qualcun altro è la mia mi fa piacere se
è stato citato legata a quella di un
papa cronista che mi ha insegnato la
curiosità per le storie facendomi fare
quel che lui non aveva potuto fare di
aree e viaggiare il giro dina mentale ce
l'ho messo io ma quella curiosità l'ha
innescata lui ed è stata cruciale e in
qualche modo cruciale quando una dozzina
d'anni fa abbiamo deciso di scommettere
sul futuro dei nostri figli e mia moglie
mandandoci da soli per sei mesi in
california
rimarranno detto tanti che non era una
roba che tutti potevano fare perché
voglio giusta ma per fortuna io l'avevo
e quindi siamo dati per sei mesi i
ragazzi hanno studiato lì è stata
un'esperienza indimenticabile per loro
ma per me è stato un terremoto ho deciso
di conoscere quanti diventare amico di
molti italiani di silicon valley e
questo è diventato un percorso nel
talento nell'identità italiana che mai
mi sarei aspettato al punto che al
ritorno un poco dopo ho deciso che
questo sarebbe stato il mio lavoro e
quindi da six john dove abitavamo sesto
san giovanni appunto a palo alto nel
cuore di silicon valley di cui non dirò
praticamente nulla o quasi parlerò di
quello che ho capito credo di aver
capito con queste connessioni balenga
due storie questa volta invece la canoa
una e la canoa che già come costantino
beltrami trascina camminando per giorni
le messi city passando dove nessun altro
bianco è passato e arrivando ad una
delle sorgenti se sia stato lui è
spirata fenimore cooper l'ultimo dei
mohicani l'altra è la canoa con cui
paolo andreani nobile contire quieto
così requiem
milanese che ha ventun anni ha sconvolto
né milano illuminista facendo con
un'impresa che molti pensavano suicida è
la prima persona dopo i mongolfiere a
salire col pallone aerostatico
ma nel 1790 fa una circa una abitazione
di grandi laghi e raccogliendo documenti
estremamente importanti centinaia di
miglia sulla canoa che cosa hanno di
particolare che dove gli altri tutti gli
altri vedevano dei selvaggi da eliminare
o forse da trasformare in civili
paolo andreani coglie la profondità e la
spiritualità e scrive delle cose
terribili che i neonati stati uniti
d'america prendono molto male su quello
che vedeva succedere nello sterminio
degli indiani
giacomo costantino beltrami in questo in
altri viaggi raccoglie dei manufatti che
oggi hanno un valore inestimabile
questi due italiani vedono qualche cosa
e quindi una civiltà profonda il valore
di un artigianato di qualità che per gli
altri era assolutamente invisibile avevo
e l'ho studiato no si portavano per
quell avventura su quella frontiera una
conoscenza un gusto estetico una
profondità di pensiero che gli altri
pionieri esploratori non potevano avere
le storie che ho raccontato di questi
due italiani le raccolte il mio amico
uno oggi uno dei più grandi esperti
mondiali di nativi americani
cesare marino e la connessione però che
voglio seguire esce da delle parole
bellissime sul talento italiano che
aveva pronunciato anni fa renzo piano
cosa abbiamo di particolare
siamo tutti i nani sulle spalle di un
gigante
il gigante dice è la cultura che ci ha
preceduti che ci da una sottile
invisibile capacità di affrontare la
complessità delle cose tessere arte in
scienze assieme articolare i
ragionamenti un'italianità dice che non
ha nulla a che vedere con l'orgoglio
naturalistico e che trova un posto a
tavola in tutto il mondo
ho ripensato a questa storia perché
incredibilmente quello che cesa del
marino per 40 anni antropologo allo
smithsonian mi aveva raccontato del suo
ingresso in un mondo che sembrava
impenetrabile coincideva con quello che
luca presso un mio amico di verona oggi
si definisce archeologo della realtà
virtuale a google ma quando lo avevo
incontrato 12 anni fa era un pioniere
della grafica digitale a dream works
qualcosa di più diverso da grafica
digitale e antropologia ma il loro
percorso da italiani incredibilmente
sembra lo stesso ho l'occasione della
vita di entrare nella mecca saluta nel
mio settore dreamworks smithsonian vado
non mi prenderanno mai il posto che
sognano tutti i grandi super esperti del
mondo e quasi subito tutti e due mi
dicono di aver capito che era il
contrario perché per la loro conoscenza
e la loro esperienza non era così ma era
così quello che pensavano fosse il punto
debole si è rivelato il punto di forza
nel loro percorso professionale
cosa abbiamo di particolare e ha
spiegato meglio ancora qualche anno fa
la persona che è stato forse il mento le
principale della mia avventura e senza
il quale forse oggi non saremmo qui
perché federico faggin
vicentino è una persona che ha firmato
il primo microchip ma sempre con persone
importanti qualcuno lo prende un po meno
sul serio ha firmato il primo microchip
e poi ha realizzato la tecnologia touch
che molti credono nei 60 realizzata da
apple ma apple ha realizzata dopo che
steve jobs abbia tentato inutilmente di
averla in esclusiva da federico
riguardo come ho disegnato il primo
microchip di esserci trovo una bellezza
estetica
mi rendo conto che essere nato e vissuto
nella città del palladio del classicismo
ti lascia dentro qualche cosa di
assolutamente
inconsapevole di fronte ad un problema
complesso io ho dato a questo problema
una soluzione con una bellezza estetica
con un'armonia è questo che abbiamo di
particolare a fronte di un problema
complesso noi italiani riusciamo a
vedere delle angolazioni diverse
non solo l'aspetto tecnico ma un
risvolto di estetica anche un risvolto
etico e un collegamento con la cultura
umanistica
se ripensiamo lui ha detto a leonardo a
marconi c'è proprio dietro questo ha
questa capacità altri molto più bravi di
fare business e sviluppo del business su
un prodotto ma noi abbiamo questa
visione d'insieme che ha un grandissimo
valore e l'ho trovato esattamente la
stessa filosofia in questo splendido
libro in cui david epstein qualche tempo
fa ha smentito appunto un luogo comune
quello dei super specialisti è un best
seller del new york times questo range
che dice che in un mondo di super
specialisti sono i generalisti quelli
che sono destinati a trionfare perché le
connessioni tra cose diverse spesso
escono da persone che non sono super
specialisti di un campo ma che sanno
creare questi collegamenti in un
infinito dei casi dallo sport alle
scienze cognitive da grandi problemi
ambientali o della ricerca scientifica
l'idea giusta è venuta da una persona
che ha saputo abbinare e collegare cose
diverse è il motivo per cui dobbiamo
ricordare e celebrare i nostri
connazionali che hanno saputo fare
questo ad un livello straordinario ma
non hanno fatto forse troppo presto
al punto che oggi sono ricordati e
celebrati molto più all'estero che non
in italia che qualcuno di recente si sia
ispirato a questi negozi per vendere i
suoi computer
l'idea di adriano olivetti non è
soltanto quella di un'impresa
straordinariamente innovativa noi quello
di saper combinare in quella ricerca di
tecnologia di prodotto etica estetica
coinvolgere grandi intellettuali e
scienziati scienziati erano solo
scrittori artisti
come non se non bastasse con una visione
umanistica la fabbrica non solo come
luogo di produzione ma come luogo di
comunità tra persone si silicon valley
forse non è una comunità di persone per
quanto incredibile tutti questi grandi
protagonisti dell'innovazione mondiale
hanno qualcosa in comune
da piccoli hanno studiato nelle scuole
che hanno seguito il metodo creato da
una grandissima visionaria
dell'ottocento
maria montessori e non è solo la persona
che ha saputo applicare la ricerca
scientifica alla pedagogia e molto di
più è una che trovo un metodo per
valorizzare bambini con handicap e con
risultati miracolosi sulle cupero di
questi bambini e quando quel metodo
viene applicato a bambini normali ha un
effetto esplosivo nella capacità di
intercettare e valorizzare questo
talento e quello che molti dei
protagonisti che abbiamo visto prima
primi paesi per primi hanno detto qual è
stato il vero chiave del loro successo
da bambini essere spinti a sfidare i
confini a credere in se stessi ma c'è
qualcosa in più nella filosofia di maria
montessori che oggi si deve coinvolgere
e cioè l'idea di attribuire a chi viene
dopo di noi e bambini un ruolo salvifico
non sono contenitori in cui noi dobbiamo
mettere delle istruzioni o devono
semplicemente apprezzano sono loro la
nostra scommessa sul futuro e quindi noi
dobbiamo investire e puntare su di loro
perché saranno loro e non saremo noi a
poter salvare il mondo in cui viviamo il
valore di tutto questo me l'ha spiegato
al meglio un mio amico di link di un
veterano anche lui olivetti perché tutto
questo e questa capacità di combinare a
questa importanza
non smetterò di ammirare la capacità
degli italiani di sentirsi a proprio
agio nella complessità anche quando
queste le caratteristiche del caos e ha
detto fabio gli americani ma direi gli
anglosassoni sono portati a semplificare
per tentare di di soave un po alla volta
ma fronte della complessità che abbiamo
davanti non credo più che questo sistema
funzioni da un approccio all italiana
sarebbe molto utile anche a silicon
valley l'elezione di montessori con cui
voglio concludere è proprio questa e
significhiamo un po a queste parole
bellissime
dette dal protagonista di un film it
stellari in cui la sfida al confine
dello spazio si intreccia con la sfida
al rapporto spazio tempo
abbiamo parlato a lungo di muri di
barriere di protette di proteggersi e
poi improvvisamente come nei confini
della realtà è uscito qualcosa di
piccolissimo che nessun muro nessuna
barriera può bloccare abbiamo dovuto per
forza cambiare la nostra prospettiva
sapevolezza capire probabilmente che
nella nostra salvezza lo si potrà
realizzare chiudendo porte in faccia
qualcun altro ma o ci salviamo tutti o
non ci salviamo e dobbiamo farlo
sperando su quelli che vengono dopo di
noi ricordando queste bellissime parole
perché dice il protagonista di inter
stella ci siamo dimenticati siamo
dimenticati che siamo pionieri
esploratori e non guardiani che questo
quello che dobbiamo lasciare a quelli
che vengono dopo di noi non tanto
conoscenza ma quanto togliere le macerie
culturali e le tante zavorre che
bloccano il loro talento sicuri che loro
affronteranno supereranno risolveranno
dei confini di cui noi non abbiamo la
minima idea noi dobbiamo solo ispirarli
e liberare il loro talento raccontare
storie e incrociarle ci aiuterà a farlo
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]